وقد حصلت الجزيره على فيديو يوثق لحظه
الاشتباك ومحاصر الشهداء الاربعه من قبل
قوات
[موسيقى]
الاحتلال
من قريه تعزون شرقي ق القليه مراس جزيره
ليث جعار نتابع معك الوضع
ليث نعم بالفعل اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال ما
بعد ساعات منتصف الليل بلده عزون الى
الشرق من محافظه قلقيليه حيث وصلت الى هذه
المنطقه كانت المقاومه قد اعدت لها كمين
قامت المقاومه بتفجير جير عبوه ناسفه ومن
ثم فتحت النار باتجاه جيش الاحتلال الذين
كانوا يتواجدون في هذه المنطقه ما ادى
لاصابه ضابط و على ما يبدو عدد من الجنود
بحسب بيان الجيش على الفور هرعت القوات
الى هذه المنطقه تم تصفيه احد المقاومين
في هذا الطريق فيما انسحب احد او ثلاثه من
المقاومين نحو وتحصنوا داخل مخزن في هذه
المنطقه حيث تم تم محاصرتهم والاشتباك
معهم حتى تم اغتيالهم معنا هنا في هذه
اللحظات الحاجه ام ام شحاده من المنطقه
واحدى الساكنات في هذه المنطقه وهي شاهده
عيان على ما جرى صباح هذا اليوم بدايه
يعني
اي كيف بدات بدا الوضع في هذه المنطقه و
من لحظه ما صحيت من النوم حسب ما حدثتنا
وسمعت الاصوات
تفضل بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
كنا نايمين صحيت على الساعه اتين على صوت
الانفجار اول شيء قمت زي المفزوع بقول ل
جوزي في شيء في الدار ببع يعني بقول لي
هذول جيش بقول له طب عنا هذول في الدار
عنا يعني الصوت هذا الجيش عننا في الدار
بقول لي لا هذا على الشارع سمعت يعني في
صوت انفجار قوي قوي كثير وضرب و وصوتيات
واطلاق بقول لك وصوات يعني اصوات الجيش
هذا في الشارع حاولت تخرج حاولت اخرج اني
انا اطلع شو في اشوف شو في اطلع شو اسمه
لا باليد حيله ما استجرنا لانهم على باب
الدار متمركزين اليهود ما استجرنا نطلع
ولا استجرنا نروح ولا نيجي ولا باليد حيله
يعني الاصوات شو اللي سمعت هون للشباب شو
كان الحديث اصوات الشباب لما صاروا
يقولوا يستنجد يعني انه تحاصرنا تحاصرنا
لا اله الا الله وانقطع الصوت ما بدر
بعدها شو صار بعد ذلك بدات الاشتباكات بعد
ذلك اه بلشت الاشتباكات مادرينا يعني انه
استشهدوا الا غير الصبحيات بعد ما انسحبوا
الجيش طلعنا لقينا يعني دم
ودم يعني واشلاء
اللي استشهدوا على
الارض شكرا شكرا لك على هذه التفاصيل اذا
يعني هذه روايه احد يعني احدى نات في هذه
المنطقه حيث تشهد على اغتيال قوات
الاحتلال بعد محاصره مجموعه من المقاومين
في داخل احد المخازن ليرتفع عدد الشهداء
منذ السابع من اكتوبر الى
224 شهيدا و منذ اعوام عده ليرتفع عدد
الجثامين المحتجزه داخل سجون الاحتلال الى
450 شهيدا من بينهم
256 شهيدا في مق الارقام شكرا لك ليث جعار
مراسل الجزيره من عزون شرقي قلقيليه ن